or action let's go by the way speaking
of action chat voted and uh it's even
closer than the other two as it should
be 52 percent of you say Hikaru Nakamura
is the favorite heading into this match
again that's about as close as it can
get to a 50 50 split so uh here we go
Nakamura Magnus Carlson
God those words feel good
I certainly do and what is this Mainline
stuff why are they playing a long
theoretical variation where they barely
spent any time and we're on move 21 and
they're trading off all the pieces
and maybe a little bit of nerves maybe
neither side wanted to play to risk it
for the biscuit chests out of the gate
and uh
now Hikaru a little worried about his
back rank that makes sense
this has seen more pieces get traded
and also from a Time perspective they
played so fast that neither player
should really get into in the kind of
time pressure that leads to blunders
although now things going a little bit
White's Direction
accepts The Rook ending
and interesting he offered a trade but
Magnus doesn't want to trade because the
white king is closer to Sarah this is
actually instructive stuff you don't say
it often in bullet yeah but instructed
to know he didn't trade because the
white King was more active
yeah
well when two heavy weights meet
sometimes there's a lot of footwork
before you see any real punches landed
and that game was an example of that
just some footwork both guys kind of
being like all right I'm where I want to
be in the Grand Final versus you know
objectively maybe the best opponent I
could be facing I think they both feel
that way and uh a draw starts things off
and now we get a benoni structure from
Black's point of view but the Knight
comes into D4 and the car quickly what
Queen b69 by Knight F5 a sacrifice
yeah it's it's it's a bit of a bluff
according to the computer but it doesn't
matter because in bullet and you
calculate everything Hikaru laughs in
the face of danger at the night and
takes E4 oldhearted
but wow there's no mate against this
King It Feels So open
yeah magnus's attack is Raging on
are way down on the clock here by the
way
yeah good call
so what's happening here blackest I have
two minor pieces
every piece is hanging and apparently
that's no good because Queen F6 at the
end I think
the queen is Under Fire yeah so now this
Queen's under attack and the rook in the
corner a white king is safer between the
two but black is up a full piece
dude these guys ability to just stare
down the barrel of
of insanity is is what separates them
right I mean I said cold-hearted really
it's cold-blooded hikaru's ability to
navigate those tactics and and Parry
that those threats Robert good try by
Magnus though
but this queen at C1 covers the G5
Square which is very important right
there the queen would have went up to G5
with a Perpetual instead of the queen on
C1 covers the king escapes Hikaru
Nakamura should take this game
yeah he's finding a way to get surgical
against that white king but Magnus
holding on
is there a Perpetual now and hikara
needs to be careful because if Magnus
was Quincy six check he can't pre-move
he would lose his Queen that's a
drawback repetition yeah is it
shakes his head couldn't find a way out
of the checks Magnus snatches a draw
from the jaws of defeat there
wow yeah a car is probably a bit unhappy
about that he was up major material uh
but Magnus he's showing off the mouse
speed now he is improving I think the
more games he plays the faster he gets
in crunch time
yeah he's he's uh keeping up the speed
that's been the one thing you wonder if
he was going to be able to do he did it
with Dania did it with alireza well he
maintains speed against Hikaru this game
this game is down five seconds
and Hikaru also
looking pretty good he just win the
exchange for free I think he did that's
that's easy money right he's up upon
right now and he's pushing his pawns
this is a knight in Bishop as this just
doesn't look good for black but if
anyone can weasel their way out it feels
like Magnus he's good at these end games
E3 and C4 yeah sorry it wasn't exchange
it was a pawn I was hallucinating there
but ultimately white is still just much
better
uh and the fact that Hikaru is also up
what is that 14 seconds on the clock
in fact Magnus just resigns just like
that we have our first decisive game of
the match at Kara Nakamura with a
one-game lead yeah Magnus says I cannot
look at that position anymore you
outplayed me good work and now it's back
to the drawing board and the openings I
feel like we haven't seen anything of
note thus far they're dabbling in
different lines but you know sometimes
we know we're gonna get a Berlin match
or we're gonna see one side out prep the
other it's just a bunch of jockeying
right now
agree but I will say the one thing we
also haven't seen is sometimes Hikaru
will play the I'll call him the dubious
Hikaru specials right where he'll play
the B3 stuff or play the openings he
knows objectively aren't great
um because he's so comfortable with them
and he knows he can he can outplay
people anyway I don't think he's messing
around with kind of dubious openings
against Magnus Robert I think that's one
thing we've seen
and although that was a mistake for Matt
apparently it was almost winning for him
and now suddenly black is the side for
Choice black is the bishop pair and
isn't losing material please take me
says Magnus I want to hit both your
Rooks and the car says absolutely not
I think he plays just like that with no
time I just
I don't know
Magnus for like the fifth time today is
sacrificing Exchange in a great way like
look at his position he has a bishop and
two pawns for Rook he also has the
healthier King his Connect Four I win
well I'll say the other thing he has is
an edge on the clock for the first time
well the writers we say that he blunders
or is there some sort of mate it's mate
G5 is coming in it's mate hey Carl has
the sack and then his Pawn should go
just push the F Pawn E5
oh but then there's yeah he gets behind
the pawn first and then he chases it
down that was well played good technique
five extra seconds on the clock for
Magnus
yeah Hikaru takes one of the pawns but
it's not enough Freddie's gonna get
frisky on the f file and uh
and Magnus is gonna level things up in
this game unless something wild happens
he also has a huge Edge on the clock
which I think was maybe the biggest
turnaround of all Robert in this game
Magnus was leading on the clock wire to
wire and did you see that Magnus went
King E3 he gave up his Pawn so it was
objectively a bad move but he's playing
faster and the car expected the pawn to
push so he pre-moved his Rook up and
that's why Max was able to steal that
rook and the game so it's two to two and
that means we are Level once more just
like at the start and look again they're
playing a quiet line almost as if
they're playing each other in a
classical match
yeah agreed this is high level opening
chess quiet lines and uh you know
there's 40 now just under 40 minutes on
the clock so
we got a lot of Chess here we've got 55
000 of you tuning in across all
platforms don't go anywhere the fun has
just begun on this Friday
I don't know if we're gonna get overtime
chess but we're gonna get a an epic
Clash no matter what well Hikaru is
going to get a pawn up Advantage because
he just stole one of those double
isolated Pawns in the center but White's
Pawn structure not healthy but who cares
how healthy it is when you're up two of
them
yeah a couple of doubled but past
e-pawns feels good
I got a rebounding here
from that loss he just had if you can if
he opened that yeah and by the way again
look at the edge of the clock this has
been an interesting match so far Robert
it feels like
the decisive games at least I know we
had a couple draws the decisive games
have been very one-sided right likes
once one player's not just winning on
the board they're dominating on the
clock and the other guy has to go back
to the drawing board Magnus just resigns
yeah you're right 100 right and also
they're switching off who has the lead
on the clock in some earlier matches one
player always Jets out to a huge time
advantage and then the other player
catches up here they're trading off
victories they're trading off time
advantages and they're also switching up
their openings I mean Magnus he did play
this style in the game that he won two
ago and hikara says if you're gonna go
for this again I'm ready and I'm
stealing a pawn in the center
yeah agreed by the way that that boat I
had earlier there were five thousand
votes from the YouTube chat which which
was 52 Hikaru Nakamura but then we have
several thousand from twitch and it's 58
hikara Nakamura so interesting both
which and YouTube slightly favoring
Hikaru in this match and Hikaru again
could be favored in this position yeah
because Rook D5 was such a superb move
there by Hikaru and Magnus he's only
down one pawn and he's trading off Queen
side pawns if he can trade off the
remaining Queen side pawns he has a draw
but Hikaru he's too smart to do that he
brings his King in and that should be
that when his King and Rook pressure the
C2 bomb
yeah though Magnus still making it
tricky this is this was awkward
this is awkward I okay can you just take
G2 Noca C4 check would have won The Rook
that's right wow what a weird turnaround
there Here Comes Magnus with a c pawn
and the clock is even which means that
mistakes might happen but the B Pawn
they're both queening but you win the
house for for black here and that means
that Hikaru has the upper hand and I
think we'll see our first two point
margin
facial expression we can easily catalog
like this
he likes he likes
oh Danny I miss commentating with you so
I'm glad we got the hikara facial reader
with us today but hakara's a beast I
think no matter what his face tells us
his play tells us that he is just
desperate to win this event not because
he's not the better player but just
because he really wants his title oh yep
oh and something happened there there
was a blunder
it was Knight F4 check possible for
Magnus I think first no before we before
he brought the queen okay
ah Knight F4 and then Queen and you win
you win the night with check okay Agnes
Magnus misplays that you can't miss
opportunities like that against Hikaru
as we said he's the king when it comes
to this format and you don't get many
chances to swing at him so Magnus missed
an opportunity there we're of course
lucky because we have the eval bar I
mean again no
no shaming and saying that that's the
truth but uh but yeah if this one ends
in a draw Hikaru maintains his two-game
lead
and it's very even but Hikaru is up a
few seconds so uh black is more active
pieces but hikara has more time with
white and this bishop now is terrible
it's locked in here that might have been
a bad decision but the Knight also is
stuck both pieces can't move yeah what
is going on with this position you've
got okay I think akaro just settles on
the oh okay yeah that's literally a draw
for as well
um that was funny it was Mutual traffic
takes me back to Hikaru on ICC beating
the Bots he would get positions just
like this close it down and then flag
the butts but here Magnus was repeating
enough times we see some a little smile
there and a draw is a fair result but a
good one for Hikaru keeps his lead
it's funny because I think a lot of
people just don't appreciate some of
these skills Hikaru has were these
aren't accidental these were these were
trained we always joking Carter was
raised on ICC right and he was a human
who was beating Bots when Bots were
first entering the online chess servers
and and he he figured out strategies to
be computers which is is really
mind-blowing when you think about it and
um that's one of the reasons he is so
resourceful so pesky and tricky on on
on the online formats and this position
I have to say at first glance it looks
really good for white uh the black king
feels less safe than the white king and
the bishop is out but the king slid to
the corner and now the black king is
being hunted
yeah Magnus well it's a victory he needs
to turn it around bring him back within
a game
looks like he's on basic or gives the
head shake
I'm not over yet but Magnus should get
this one Black's King is wide open you
just got to figure out a way to break
through if your Magnus
yeah Queen D5 Queen D7 looks like a good
way to do just that and oh can you take
it he doesn't bring the queen in
yeah I think white can bring the queen
to F7 and then push this Pawn
yeah you are trying to make things oh
you got Queen G1 C1 Queen outside chance
of Perpetual
oh
[Laughter]
that's pretty funny
oh gosh he you know he he waves his hand
by the way Hikaru streaming of course
you saw that delayed reaction that was
pretty funny
didn't see the queen
and it's a one-point match once again
Danny and Hikaru going to again one of
these quiet positions so these two have
been engaging in combat in the end game
yeah protest Gambit declined I love that
give a decline the rare the very rarely
cited botesque Gambit declined there
um but okay if Magnus wins this one
Robert then we will be level with 30
minutes like a regular match right
remember we had 45 minutes to start this
this final uh so we get extra chess
between these two guys which is great
but if Magnus wins it basically is a
wash and we're back to 30 minutes with
the tide match what is happening the
eval bar is doing push-ups over there
going up and down and it seems like
there's an incredible amount of tension
what is yeah
how does this survive for hit card the
king's getting checked but there's
there's no rookie three I'm like looks
like peace okay rookie three comes he
takes the rook and it's a car who's on
the prowl
wow
and the H Pawn is running Harry or the
win
and by the way a flex on the clock in
this game by hikar look at that that is
a massive time Advantage bullet and
Bishop E4 was a great move there by
Hikaru he knew to trade pieces off
because their ensuing end game would be
so nice for him he gets that win and I
think Magnus was blinded both by the
sunlight and by hikara's great moves
yeah Magnus needs to get a little help
with the curtains and uh get a little
help on the board right now with hikar
Nakamura taking a two-game lead as we
reach the 30 minute Mark and uh he's on
four and I guess he's answering the
question that he isn't Rusty despite
having watched Magnus for the last two
hours he's ready to now play magnet and
did you make an unintentional Greg
shahadi ICC reference by talking about
curtains if you want to throw back to
ICC usernames we can do some trivia
which is fun shout out to Hawkeye we
miss we miss uh we missed that guy
um but uh
yeah anyway curtains
uh this looks pretty nice for black
there's a great light Square Bishop for
one sign and a not so great light Square
Bishop for the other and the black king
is also more active
yeah Black Ink finds the nice E5 Square
even though yeah he goes through the
bishop ending
not a position that white should be able
to win especially when you're the one
down six seconds on the clock so Hikaru
continuing
to do what he does but
a lot of time left though we got tons of
time
oh he's trying to trick him I was like
how could you give this access point but
there's Bishop A2 check and Bishop
would have been lost
these guys are full of Tricks silly
rabbits tricks are for kids although not
in bullet chess
bricks are for everyone in bullet this
bishop is on the best possible Square
it's keeping the king out of both
directions but that was smart by Hikaru
he trades some pawns the 50 move rule
starts once again and unless Magnus can
take both these pawns he is going to
lose this game on the clock yeah
you are flexing the time the time what
you gotta do yeah I wonder how good
these guys are in bullet compared to my
accuracy score and classical Cuts if I
had to guess they're better at bullet
than I am at classical desk just saying
like this is insane and look at Magnus
that's what hikari's gonna do is put his
Bishop on the I think on G6 at some
point and yeah he's gonna take the
bishop and then yeah he did it
and the pre-move or the win just as long
as you don't accidentally stalemate or
repeat a position three times Magnus
shakes his head
knows that Hikaru got the better of the
the the metabolic game there
and that's the third time that a car has
done that he beat alireza fuja twice in
that same exact end game with bishop and
wrong corner for The Rook pawn and now
Hikaru has built his lead up and in
addition to his three-point lead he's
got a really nice position in this game
with the uncompromised pawn structure on
the king side for white and blacks King
side and shambles
yeah and now you see the difference in
body language hikara with the head Bob
feeling that ABBA Dancing Queen
only seven okay that's what he's
listening to by the way
um
the car just on the prowl right now dude
look at this
it lights up a piece
up a piece about to go up four games in
the match up four seconds on the clock
Magnus no longer bobbing his head to
t-swift someone needs to change the
momentum for Mr Carlson the only good
news that I can think of for Magnus is
he lost six games in a row against Ali
Reza and he still won the match Hikaru
is next level right that is the final
boss but he has lost a series of games
then was able to go on a winning streak
of his own so that at least should give
him some confidence in the back of his
mind
yeah agreed that's the point we were
making at the start of the match is that
because Magnus was down against all the
residents and came back that has to pay
dividends here at least from a
psychological perspective if you're if
you didn't see that match Magnus was
down three games Robert with five
minutes to go
like yes he was winning the game to make
it too but that was that was impressive
and he ended up really turning around so
Magnus is not going to go quietly into
the night here no of course not he
always is a fighter and now we're
getting to end game and hikaru's
actually been out playing Magnus in many
of these end games he's aided by the
clock he has a slight lead in this game
as well but look at the peace placement
he goes for C5
yep and the car was just feeling it he's
really flexing it right now enjoying the
tune I don't know maybe that's maybe
that is an Ava because that doesn't look
like a dancing queen bee no it looks uh
hmm I wonder what he's like listening to
I was gonna just throw out a random
musician but
I I will ask him when it's done
he's trying to listen to anything all
right the beat of his movie yeah again
the creepy thing would be that he's not
listening to any music oh my God and
Magnus blunders a piece tomorrow
maybe gonna take another one
and you know we we asked a question
would Hikaru be rusty because Magnus is
the one who played two matches Robert
but the other flip side was Will
magnus's momentum turned into exhaustion
and if this one gets away from him I
think I think at this point it just
might be that uh kind of ran out of
steam here against the final boss as you
said
unreal play thus far from icaro he's
fast he's playing very accurately and
he's getting to the end games where he
can play for two results as we say in
classical chess he knows that if Magnus
plays Super quickly he might hold a draw
but otherwise Hikaru can use the clock
as the main weapon
or into one of our mods Magnus Hikaru
was listening to some Bollywood Hits
by the way if you haven't seen RR
fantastic film sorry back to the test
now don't apologize I just watched it
the other night
you know everyone wants to be beam out
there
that was I do okay we can't turn this
into a movie podcast all right so
staying on the chest here Hikaru Harry's
well was a lot of pressure but Magnus
still has an edge with the bishop pair
so also the biggest note is that he's
not that down on the clock right it's
very close I think that's huge for
Magnus to keep the speed up
yeah and look at this end game it is
even material two Bishops against Bishop
Knight pair and Magnus should be better
but I'm not sure he trusts himself that
he might even look at this position one
that he in the back of his head he wants
to win but at the same time he's like I
don't want to lose on time
yeah
you don't want to lose on time but uh
you also don't want to lose on the board
at this point I don't think Magnus is in
danger of losing on the board
but can he create enough for a win you
got to start racking up some dubs here
down by five and the pawns trading off
is really good news for the night right
the night is a slow moving piece the
Bishops they look across the board in a
better way E5 is dropping but then A3
would be captured so uh yeah I was
desperately Clinging On to both of his
Pawns
yeah he's trying to create some sort of
Swindle he does manage to steal one but
Hikaru
wait okay
there's some chances to win here and
time is even enough that Magnus could
convert this
no I think what Magnus could have done
was take this Pawn you go to Bishop E6
and took it I'm worth it I'm getting
flagged and he takes the pawn right now
yep
there you go there you go
a draw apparently
icaro has crossed lines that very few
should Venture into he's listening to
Nickelback
whoa look at this Photograph Danny every
time I do it makes me laugh
although I will say why does Nickelback
get so much hate what is the deal with
Nickelback getting all the hate I don't
know but all the answer that we all want
is like what was on Joey's head can you
just get that
what the hell was on Joey said
this is where I grew up you know the I
grew up watching these two in some ways
online not really I'm an old man but uh
that's how I there are some people
growing up watching these guys
it's true and uh as we get back to the
chest white is up a pawn it's a Magnus
needs to show that Magnus technique and
he brings his King all the way up
but he's dropping pawns and I'm worried
about him losing another game
yeah the Knight is just so pesky there
the king is in a in a danger zone for
sure there are mating net possibilities
although look at the aggression I like
this F5
if we're trading to The Rook ending
uh well Carl's fine sorry yeah it does
well it was actually doing fine I mean
Magus needs to be reminded of who he
really is you know he's going to the end
game it needs to be reminded of who he
really is
um
now he stops to calculate I think he's
not wait what happened no no he realized
that he was winning because he's on a
delay because he's streaming so he's
like I could have just captured his rook
and won the end game
oh it was Perpetual okay I didn't
realize that they
that it was a draw yeah but he just
realized he was winning if he had traded
Rooks
oh this looks really bad for Hikaru
though like I know Hikaru sometimes
plays some dodgy stuff but handing your
opponent the light squares in front of
your king
feels like a bad idea usually
arrow is
he uh he couldn't make it as a wise man
maybe he'll make it as a poor man
stealing although right now Magnus is
going to steal one
Danny okay that game reminds us of who
Magnus Carlson is this is how you remind
us Magnus of who you really are
yeah I don't know if I want to keep
going in this Nickelback which I can
like I can if you want
um you can post it all day this is we
should I wonder if one day we'll confess
how many times you and I have played the
game where we were sneaking words on the
show because our producers don't want to
know that but every once in a while
Talent has to uh you know
we won't go there but every once in a
while we have fun I mean Danny come on
let's be real someday somehow I'm gonna
make it all right but not right now
okay make it all right right now because
he's down a lot in the match but he's
better in this position because he's
going right after hikaru's King
yeah he is although he's still down five
games oh I feel like he just won didn't
that make it four maybe I missed
something
um well I think we missed a lot because
we were seeing it we were you know stuck
in
in the Nickelback references which is uh
you know never go full Nickelback as
they say
I agree with that chat the car is so
good he's been playing Amazing chess but
in this game look at hikaru's King it's
wide open and Magnus isn't even down any
material for this attack
yeah Magnus is rolling here
and it is a four game it is a four game
I'm glad that even when I lose my focus
cold Nickelback I was I was uh on top of
the score there Magnus should bring this
to three games unless something crazy
happens although I'm not going to doubt
those Knights this is
this is this is uh
okay he's doing a good job cleaning up
the tactics no more Forks push him baby
and uh Magnus brings us to Slaves here
no no Magnus is slow right now he's down
to six seconds really he should get this
done but he's playing very slowly
yeah Hikaru is removing the bleep out of
this okay but that was good seconds that
was really nice by Magnus there uh to
push his F Pawn get his King involved
and not fall for a fork so Magnus it's
back to three points he's feeling better
you can see it on his face but hey Karu
still has a healthy lead in the match
18 minutes to go remember we had 45
minutes to start which ultimately is
huge for Magnus because at this point if
it was 30 minutes probably would be down
and out right so this is um this is
exactly what we what we uh wanted to see
the most chest possible between these
two guys in a final
and uh Magnus is uh turning the momentum
around
yeah I mean Magus is asking could you
say goodbye to yesterday because If
Today Was Your Last Day you gotta win
this bullet challenge
yeah
you you are Shameless you're Shameless
oh well back to the uh to the bullet
here it looks like Magnus with the black
pieces he's much better because his King
is safer and he's going after hikaru's
Pawns
yeah and if A2 Falls this is one of the
positions that it's it's it's hard to
lose as black that's the other problem
is that Magnus is up on the clock and
there are any tricks right sometimes
you're losing but there you know there's
weirdness to come there's Knife Works
there's King safety in this position the
uh
the game is a pretty easy one for black
to play yeah you're up a pawn and a
clear extra one here's Bishop C he wants
the outermost Pawn bring the king over
to E8 and play Bishop d8 I think that's
what oh again with the a pawn for the
d-pawn but that was a surprising
decision
yeah
I yeah I don't know that that improves
his winning chances so right as I say
that maybe Hikaru is in a position to
hold this that would be
unfortunate or Magnus for his momentum
to come to a screeching halt and by the
way a car will up enough on the clock
that that
this could get dangerous yes it really
could and now you see both players
scrambling at the moment and look at
that defense from a car he plants his
Bishop in front of the pond and now he's
the one with the active king and a
passer of his own
what is going on there
we ain't ending invited seven seconds
for Magnus 10 for Hikaru
and Magnus wants to trade Queens but not
at that point no he didn't want trade
Queens right there
oh wait the white was winning if you
took because
some weird opposition yeah no the king
the white King was he took on D6 and
King C8 white was winning yeah
dude that's crazy though that's two end
games Hikaru has missed the chance to
trade into a winning King and pawn
ending and again we don't have time you
know this is not the most instructive
Chef show you're ever going to watch on
Twitch everyone uh because this bullet
but yeah white was winning due to
irregular flanking opposition there and
uh crazy stuff
yeah that was pretty wild and it's hard
to trade like that because your king is
so far away you think I might lose the
game and that is definitely not
something that a car wants and you know
what he's doing he is waiting he doesn't
go down to one second left and then make
bishop H6 it will be a three-time
repetition the game will be a draw but
at least he burns 30 more seconds off
the match clock
yeah and he's pausing to make sure he
does that
um and playing The Meta game taking a
sip of that giant mug of water
there's not really much to do here
looking at this analysis every time I do
it makes me laugh every time I do it
make me
I can't do it anymore dude I'm trying to
wean off the Nickelback references
because otherwise I'm going to burn it
to the ground
sorry I was slow on the update there
reading chat and that laugh was probably
a little unnecessary I'm so glad it's
the weekend
um
all right well the draw the draw comes
to akaranakamura he has a 10-7 lead
well uh we'll switch that scoreboard
here in just a second but yeah that draw
earns some time off the clock and
um
and Hikaru Nakamura maintaining his lead
yeah he's really playing a great match
but Magnus is making it more and more
competitive not just by the scoreboard
but just the way Magnus is played in
many of these games but I like what
hikar is doing here look at how even
this position is and it's a complete
draw and that allows Hikaru to burn even
more time off the clock because he's not
going to lose this game and Magnus you
know if he doesn't play quickly at some
point a car may say I'm not making a
draw anymore I'm gonna try to flag you
yeah but I'm just furious right now with
our mods who did a poll for the best
Nickelback song where's photograph oh
photographs at the top agreeing because
I missed it yeah photograph there you go
photograph is is probably their best
song
yeah of course it is
yeah
another another king and pawn ending
Hikaru gonna get as much time off the
as he can although I will say this
at this point the meta of getting time
off the clock isn't that relevant yet
right this is not the type of lead
Robert that is devastating it's a
three-game lead remember if it even gets
within one game we have overtime chess
because the new rules are that you have
to win bullet matches by two so I'm just
pointing out that regardless of the fact
that we're losing time here I I don't
think that he's in a position to really
protect the lead like that yet yeah it
takes me back to hikar versus Wesley so
and those speeches championships where
they did this forever it felt like
because there was increment which made
it worse because you could make a little
pawn move at some point and then start
over again uh in pure bullet with zero
seconds added per move yeah someone's
gonna uh flag they can't just wait
forever so the 50 move rule happened and
now we see in this game Magnus he's
going for it he is on the offensive on
the king side but has he overextended
a nice strike by hakara to play F5
that's actually a really thematic
instruction point I know we said we
don't get a lot of analysis and bullet
everybody but that was a really great
thing because white has also opened his
King with the spawn storm and that's
what black points out with this F5 move
so Hikaru makes it spicy and both kings
are in danger
what's going on here the queen went up
to C4 black blocked it is there trouble
on this E6 square if you can TR you just
dropped the pawn on E6
there was a knight on E6 he could have
taken this Pawn on D6 so Magnus with the
oversight and now Hikaru I mean he looks
like he's getting a knight F3 in there
yeah
wow
the car turned that around consider it
done as far as Nickelback Nickelback
references in an interview consider it
done maybe we'll do that all of us are
in the inside joke oh whoa
Knight takes E2
too
yeah that and look at the time Hikaru
was kind of burning some of the clock
and then he made that move and it was a
rough decision and Magnus when Bishop G5
allowing this he had better options but
he just wants to make a draw he does not
want to lose on time he just wants to
grab these last Pawns
yeah he's only got six seconds
keeps a pawn he has winning chances but
Magnus will have none of it that one got
away from Hikaru and again I know we've
seen Hikaru doing more of the meta
bullet things here milking the clock
protecting a lead but with 11 minutes
plus to go here
you know we already saw Magnus overcome
a three-game deficit in five minutes
versus Ali Reza farusia so this is this
is close
I'm totally with you I think that Hikaru
is trying to use that strategy to his
Advantage but in some of these games
it's his disadvantage you'd rather win a
game in 20 seconds than draw a game in a
minute there's still enough time for
Magnus to make this comeback and look at
this position it's very sharp where
white has an extra Pawn or did have an
extra Pawn over there on the queen side
now black is in the driver say D5 is
that's a weakness and whoa that was a
quick spot by Magnus
yeah yeah
he's gonna have a couple extra pawns
here plus the bishop versus knight
Dynamics should be better for black only
thing you have to watch out for usually
is the time against Hikaru but Magnus
also up five seconds on the clock here
so a good turnaround
or Carlson
uh oh yeah but that open King Hikaru is
not gonna make this easy spying some
tactics
because we just fell and now it looks
like we're into an end game that
unfortunately for Magnus should be a
drop but now look at the clock Magnus is
the one up a few seconds he's also up a
pawn he should try to win this game
he should and now he's got to pass
e-pawn this is a lot harder to hold than
it looks for white if Magnus can uh
can keep his cool on the clock he is
still up three seconds that's huge
yeah this is not easy
this is up to F5 oh also E3 this is
objectively now it's objectively losing
for white Magnus in position to bring
this back to two games
oh but he car tricked him Hikaru tricked
him when the Rook is in front the king
could come back to the second rank but
if the The Rook wasn't back there there
was gonna be an E1 checking now his car
is going up on time oh my goodness and
he's the one who could win
on the board I mean okay it's gonna be a
draw but I wonder if he should have
traded Rooks there that's crazy
wow
wow I mean what a save
that was incredible he understood that
if his Rook was behind upon what you'd
normally want he couldn't get his King
back so he drops The Rook to the first
rank brings it in front of the pawn and
his King was able to Scamper back just
in the Nickelback of time so that was a
nice save there for a Hikaru Nakamura
and and now we have another game that's
Mainline stuff
uh
uh and yeah we're gonna do the game chat
where all of us are on this inside joke
and Robert and I are going to try to
squeeze Nickelback references into the
interview and it'll be awesome it's
gonna be fun
um I don't know who we're going to be
interviewing we still got a long ways to
go
I will say that again I know it's a
three-game lead but hikaros had his
chances Robert objectively I think to
make the lead bigger we know we missed
those spots in a couple of end games
right where he didn't convert to the
king upon ending so
will it come back to haunt him right now
Magnus again threatening to make it a
two-game lead okay he's should be
winning this I don't see how you stop
this Pawn unless you give up your rook
in A7 right now who cares about this
bishop you're getting this queen Magnus
he wins a quick game there it's only a
two-point spread that's huge that's huge
exactly no this is uh again I think that
I it's it's too early to provide
criticism overall in any sort of mass
strategy but I do think Hikaru protected
his lead a little bit with a couple of
those draws and Magnus saved
Magnus held on and now might have a
little bit of momentum as we head into
the final minutes
and now we have another complicated
opening where uh black is attacking on
the queen side and also White's not
attacking anywhere because the Rook on
C8 keeps White's pieces honest
yeah we need to was a nice little trick
he goes and steals that pawn
whoa But Here Comes Carlson on the
second rank
is there
takes an F4 so you miss something better
I don't know what it was but it clearly
the eval bar instead of being all the
way down for black it went back towards
the middle and somehow a car was
escaping
how
yeah I don't know how Hikaru escaped
that that and now now it's turning
around the other way 93
he blundered the end game he always got
an extra Pawn on the outside
no this is just great for a car in fact
he's winning I think if I'm Magnus I
might just resign
wow
oh and as soon as I say that his car
blunders the pawn
our blender's right back
what's the time 28 to 18 seconds so
Hikaru should oh F6 check he pre-moved
it ikaro played King E5 and Magnus had
pre-moved F6 the house Falls with the E6
pawn and what a huge win for Hikaru that
is to keep magnus's momentum back and
you could just see the pain in magnus's
face as they get into another end game
no Queens on the board in this one uh
seems to be the match strategy for these
Players let's go down to the end game
white has the bishop pair but we'll see
if Magnus is still reeling from that
loss he needed to hold that game but he
still does have enough time to get a
couple wins here
Danny this just looks really good for
Magnus to my eyes in the eval bars
absolutely unfazed
yeah
looks great for white but it's also a
closed position that could go for a
while here the defile being the only
open one so it's I'm starting to play
the metagame Robert I'm looking at the
time again Magnus did overcome three
games in five minutes for borugia but
Nakamura is a different animal and uh
you're starting to get up against it
where the closed positions are are ones
you just have to avoid even if you're
better but now black is better and the
pushes his Pawn so maybe some trades
will happen opposite colored Bishops
there's a check on D5 here sorry why is
black better because the B Pawn is just
that strong
asking me you know
eval Bar Needs a raise now that is a pun
I could get behind right there
um
okay Magnus finds a way to get the
counter play
unfortunately though it this is a draw
that's going to take another 30 seconds
off the total game clock for sure the
car is going to milk this all the way to
the end and we're going to be under five
minutes
and if you're a car I don't think you
pushed the beep on you might just lose
that end game as black will be up a
piece but white will have these past
pawns that will roll up the board so
Magnus needs to go like King G5 back to
F5 back and forth over there and Hikaru
might yeah he goes in he goes in for the
win he goes for it
he's losing oh F4
and here man
Magus just needs to move it doesn't
matter if you blunder what a huge
momentum shift here
oh my gosh
what a momentum shift
Magnus Carlson wins to bring this within
two games and we have four minutes and
45 seconds left I spoke too soon I
thought I thought it was a dead Ops Code
Bishop ending Hikaru should have taken
the draw and then a car brought his King
in he could have repeated at any moment
and he saw the Grimace on his face that
was one of those I shouldn't have done
that why did I do it and speaking of why
is it doing things what is this opening
for white it looks really bad
yeah
this is where Hikaru is
you gotta take a breath and not go into
the the kind of dubious opening Lane
that again sometimes he can revert to
which works against 99.99 of people in
bullet but Magnus is going to get
positions like this and be better if the
car replaced those weird openings just
light Square domination you can't kick
that whoa a queen sack on G4
wow
he made that actually so quickly looks
pretty good yeah
that was that was ridiculous that might
be one of the most ridiculous moments of
the match
he's losing the game though yeah
he's losing the game now it's falling
apart and that King is in a lot of
danger what a move there G5 by the way
forcing The Rook to the awkward square
and this is going to be a one game match
with three minutes to go everybody
buckle up
you're looking at a couple of rock stars
where the chess comes easy and the
blunders are cheap
Danny I thought you were saving me from
all the Nickelback references and then
what what wait wait the car is wondered
and and it seems like Magus could have
taken more advantage of it but didn't
but still he has the better position and
the safer King a knight into D5 the
bishop slicing across the board a long
range piece against the black king
yeah the momentum again we've seen it
happen Magnus overcame momentum against
Borussia very similar to this down three
games with about five minutes left now
he's only down by one and uh you gotta
win by two thanks for everything you
just said Captain Obvious of your walk I
do appreciate it but you know what I
would do if I'm hikar here I'm looking
at the overall match clock but it's only
a one point spread look to flag Magnus
Bishops are more difficult to move than
Rooks in time scrambles mag is doing the
right thing pushing his Pawn all over
the board it's a bishop and three pawns
for a rook and yet here I am saying look
at the clock and look at Icarus chances
yeah
yeah objectively the chest is good for
white here but the Rook is so much
easier to play in these spots the bishop
is stuck you can't pre-move like look at
this The Rook can already pre-move in a
way that white cannot and that's such a
practical advantage in these games but
he's going hey he's going for the age
goes for it but he had to take time on
it yeah he's moving very slowly and
Hikaru playing oh a repetition I don't
think that's good for Hikaru I felt like
he could have played on
yeah yeah I think he should have played
King E5 there instead of the last Rook
A5 and allowed the game to go on now
you're down to a game though that it
could be it right if Hikaru wins this
game
that's it Magnus gotta win to send us
into overtime or at least not lose
and what is this opening it looks very
adventurous and White's King is safely
castled blast King remains in the center
but black does have the pair of Bishops
so I would say initial Advantage white
but if the Checkmate attack doesn't
happen quickly then black suddenly might
be right back in this
agreed F6 it's a spicy move
and you want that Knight on D5 but he
wants more than just a trade
wow Rook enters the center But Here
Comes Bishop E3 but Brook D3 oh he
walked into it
oh yeah check I missed the check oh
everybody missed the check I mean we're
in scary territory this queen just
wrapped around a B5 but it's doing
nothing over there in fact the E4 Pawn
is about to drop and the F6 part is also
weak in the end game
no one knows what's going on here least
of all the eval bar it's a five second
time Advantage though for Hikaru which
is huge if things stay the same Magnus
has got to make something happen or he's
gonna get flagged yes if Madness is
going to lose he better keep an eye on
the match clock and then resign
immediately because there's still time
left and he would have a chance to win
that game but oh it's getting bad for
him it looks like the Evo bar is saying
white is better
that's a brilliant point if Magnus is
going to lose he needs to resign like
like now yes but it's unclear you know
in this position looks like black is the
one who's doing well he's stealing the
pawns but his clock is down under what's
going on I'm in seconds he's grabbing
all the pawns he's gotta go he has to
rush this like he's never rushed before
yep 10 seconds here comes the A4
you missed it tight match
time match
get one more game God I think there were
seconds on the clock so this game
doesn't start the sixth move um mini
match that they would have to see who
can win by two I will get word from our
producers but he went Rook before I'm
not sure if he was going for a cheeky
you know my opponent might remove or he
mounts it but either way Magnus takes
the game and we are knotted up at 13 and
a half
omg's or snaps there's a reason those
emotes exist for subscribers emotes like
this because we freak out when bullet
chess happens and this is uh
this is crazy and Hikaru again
just felt like he he snatched a defeat
snatched a draw there from the from the
jaws of Victory he he and magnus's gotta
get credit for keeping in those games by
the way Magnus now up on the clock here
this is a renewed sense of faith in his
ability to win this match and while we
are seeing some trades the H4 Pawn is
loose that Bishop on G7 hitting the E5
Pawn but I think Magnus with the lead on
the clock and I would take his position
even though that Rook just landed in the
enemy camp
completely agreed you gotta like White's
position here this is this is regulation
we have had it confirmed We Believe by
production and game Ops who are behind
the scenes making sure well
what was rookie four he's going for a
rook lift I guess there was a knight F6
check and opening up the e-file huh
there's something here apparently there
is he goes Queen DJ he wants to work
deep with a mating attack the queen
blocks and she said yeah
there was Queen takes F3 there for Black
by the way everyone that's why he
retreated to D3 Hikaru trying to get the
Queens off the board who's better here
with the a pawn the Eep I have no idea
what's going on well Magnus just settle
on a draw no I think he does and you see
Magnus he's mad at himself because he
was up about seven seconds the match
remains tied now we are into overtime
and so this it changes things it's we
still win by two and they got six games
so after the sixth game if there's
someone in the lead they win the match
even if it's just a one point margin
Danny this is what the people wanted
this is what the people wanted it's what
they signed up for I am uh I am just
sitting here like a little kid
just bundled up on Christmas opening
presents knows that all of them were
gonna be great doesn't matter I don't
even know what's going on or any other
holiday
I'm excited hey you like to open
presents I think Magnus wants to open
the C file this Rook would have caused
some problems but he doesn't do that
instead he gives himself Foursquare and
goes to the B file and watch out the A2
Pawn is hey rugby two
oh my God that's nasty if you take it
we're gonna have a baby girl Brittany on
B1 you can't give black oh my God it's
all falling apart here
Hikaru will be down in the match by the
way
for the first time today if he loses
Hikaru has not trailed in this match
wait what what is Max's Queen just go he
didn't Retreat it he got brought it back
to F7 but he goes for this and maybe we
spoke too soon
what just happened
oh my gosh this F6 Pawn is hanging
how did that happen
any pre-moved King h8 and he's just
losing the game
wow
well
I gave a commentator's curse earlier
and it backfired on Hikaru Nakamura I
guess I just cursed Magnus there because
I am shocked that hecaro Nakamura has
won that game
drop his Queen back when he was stealing
all the Pawns in the position maybe he
just didn't realize there's a bishop on
B3 before that he didn't realize he
could go back but that's a thing of the
past and right now magnets with the
white pieces has a nice position but
he's down five seconds so he needs to go
after this D6 Pawn he needs a hammer
away at Hikaru setup did he just oh he
got so fortunate oh my God it was loose
so so lucky he blundered the skewer but
it didn't matter
they are worse in this position but as
you said up a few seconds on the clock
but again it's win or go home literally
if anyone earns a two-point margin
everybody that's it ship it we're done
what is happening here The Rook B3 the
steals a pawn but the open C file watch
out for the black king
oh they're making mistakes both though
of course it's bullet it happens but
there's apparently winning 367 free
night
free 97 it was just hanging oh he's
still hanging oh he sees it the third
time
oh my gosh
agreed these games never disappoint
oh my gosh hey Carl on a little bit of a
delay that's the moment where his Knight
was hanging
and now Bishop is hanging it's not over
though oh he just dropped a second piece
so he first off then a bishop and his
Queen's not trapped but look at Magnus
just get those Queens off the board and
then oh he didn't even have to the car
resigned
yeah yeah Ricardo throws in the towel
we're back to tide
all netted up in 15 games a piece moving
on to our third game in overtime
everybody
I haven't seen in overtime this good
since UConn Syracuse back in that big
East tournament this is really some epic
stuff I mean they must both be super
nervous at this stage and look at Magnus
adopting this french-like structure
without a light Square Bishop
yeah good for black here Magnus
increasing his space advantage on the
queen Side High Level chess and bullet
look at this move King D7 by the way oh
connecting the Rooks
it's a great end game that's what they
say right I hate on the French in the
opening but when you get to the end game
it's almost always better for black
because the base Pawn F7 very hard to
get to and look at White's pawns they're
sticking out a bit yep yep opposite
position you want to be in in a French
also no Edge on the clock this time for
Hikaru he is staring down what could be
his first deficit in the match and the
last time you said it you jinx Magnus
this time you almost did as well
apparently but look at that these
Knights they're going right after this
rook and if Rook C2
what is happening here
I have no idea
he's gonna take C1 and be down the
exchange but he's got some compensation
doesn't want it
and his car is in huge trouble Magnus
just has to take why did he spend like
five seconds on that turn he is wasting
time
yeah now he's losing the C pawn and he
doesn't even win the material back
this is going the wrong direction for
hikar for Magnus okay but he did go up a
piece here
and wow
Knight F5 go give a check just give a
check somewhere what's the time oh but
you got 10 to 7 Seconds here and it's
now under super dangerous for Magnus
yeah he's pre-moving he's trying his
best oh he's blowing the A5 pod and now
a car is taking it and he's taking the
G6 Pawn so if the Rooks come off oh my
God White's even better now oh my gosh
and Matt just lost the time
wow
he screams at the screen unbelievable
I don't know what he's yelling about but
that is not what you wanted Hikaru
maintains a one-game lead or regains a
one-game lead and Magnus has never LED
in this match
and I think part of it is your fault the
commentator's curse strikes again oh
shut up I mean no you do the talking hey
we're not rooting friends every time
every time Magnus gets close to taking
his first lead again to just joining
Hikaru has led this match wire to wire
Magnus completed at one point what was
it a four was it five games at one point
uh it balloons up to quite a substantial
difference between them but I guess
they're chatting maybe Hikaru because
his matches haven't been close he
doesn't know that overtime is still a
win by two ah they're checking to see
what game they are so that is very smart
uh that is really smart by both of them
they're seeing how many games do we have
left before it becomes sudden death
yeah
yeah so they're chatting with the team
uh staff confirmed it was five games of
a lead for Hikaru Nakamura at one point
in fact at a couple different points
Hikaru had a five game lead so we are in
overtime chess here both players
confirming where the match sits
it's a win by two scenario unless we get
to six games and then it's sudden death
whoever wins is your bullet chess
champion although actually if Magnus
Carlson wins we get more chess so for
the content many people rooting for
magnets for the uh for the Hikaru fans
they don't want to see any more chefs
and who do you think that little stall
favorite because Magnus lost the game
but both players must be nervous so do
you feel like any side gets the upper
hand thanks to that mini break
I think with players like this who are
just objectively so good it probably
doesn't really matter
um but you have to believe it always
favors the person who lost the game to
be able to take a breath so maybe Magnus
can kind of control his uh his emotions
for a moment he is up he is up a little
bit in terms of space here
oh and that D6 Pawn is the worst Pawn on
the board if you can get around your
dark Square Bishop so yeah a little bit
extra space for Magnus but a lot of
extra time for Hikaru five seconds at
the moment
and whoa what just happened what just
happened there I look away for a second
and it's like vacuumed off the board
yeah everything just exited hey Carl
probably okay with its raw even though
that doesn't win the match because he's
black gives him another chance to win
with white remember win by two unless we
get to get to Seven to the seventh game
this is an incredibly played game thus
far Danny I've been watching the eval
bar it hasn't moved they put all the
best moves to this point and black gives
off a piece but gets a bunch of Pawns
and it's gonna be a draw by Perpetual
Jack
should play for a win look at the clock
he should he should and he knows it and
he does it Hikaru going in away there
was a blunder maybe six yeah this part
is promoting he allowed the queen in the
party you see it on magnus's face he
knows
it's over oh my God and that
and that does it it's having Nakamura
defended his bullet just championship
title oh my goodness that was a Clash of
Titans and akaro speaking to his fans
his audience on his stream but Magnus
he's as disappointed there with a second
place finish but Hikaru he didn't
Trail a single time in the match and
Magnus almost made it happen but almost
is not good enough
a wire to wire victory for the reigning
bullet chess champion Magnus Carlson
will not get one of the only titles in
chess that has evaded him at this point
in his career
Nakamura is still
the bullet just yet